I hate California I want to go to East
Coast I want to go where culture is like
me Morgan I research or at least
Connecticut or New Hampshire writers
within the woman to those schools anyway
mom should just go to City College you
know with your work ethic just go to
City College and then to jail and then
back to City College and then maybe
you'd learn to pull yourself off and not
expect everybody everything
Lady Bird is that your given name yeah
why is it in quotes I gave it to myself
it's given to me by me Lady Bird always
says that she lives in the wrong side of
the tracks but I always thought that it
was like a metaphor but there are actual
train tracks what she did was very
baller very anarchists she has a big
heart
dear mom she's warm but she's also kind
of scary you can't be scary and warm I
think you can your mom is so you are not
interested in any Catholic colleges no
way
I want schools like Yale but not Yale
because I probably couldn't get in you
definitely couldn't get in does mom hate
me you're tired we can sit up I'm not
tying or dragging your feet
you are so infuriating stop yelling I'm
not yelling Oh perfect love it you both
have such strong personalities
when is a normal time do you have sex
you're having sex just wanted it to be
special
why you're gonna have so much fun
special sex in your life we're afraid
that we will never escape our past
whatever we give you it's never enough
it's never enough we're afraid of what
the future will bring we're afraid we
won't be loved
we won't be like yeah well you know your
mom totally and we won't succeed I want
you to be the very best version of
yourself that you could be
what if this is the best version
[Music]
what it really like is to be on Math
Olympiad but math isn't something you're
very strong in that we know of yet
[Music]
you